good morning John sometimes there's a
bisexual space alien scientist who just
wants to cut out half of his ex-lovers
brain so that he can use that half of a
brain to create a perfect sexual
companion yes John
I love Rocky Horror but I'm very
ambivalent about Glee doing Rocky Horror
like that Rocky Horror is in a way at
least being exposed to a new generation
I like that RT is finally going to have
something to do that isn't really
awkward because there is a
wheelchair-bound person in Rocky Horror
but it.if not doing it for me and it's
not doing it for a lot of people so from
the perspective of a guy who used to be
in Rocky Horror cast and who really
loves Rocky Horror it's trying to figure
out what it is that is bothering me
about Glee doing Rocky Horror so here's
a big secret about Rocky Horror that's
very difficult for people like myself to
admit the Rocky Horror Picture Show is a
very very very very bad movie it's
terrible the sets are terrible the
dialogue is terrible the songs at least
the vast majority of them aren't very
good there's a line in one of the songs
for example don't get hot and the hot
stud use a bit of mustard mustard it's
the only cure for being all hot and
flustered so if you confront me and tell
me the Rocky Horror Picture Show was
terrible I will argue with you for days
but subjectively it totally is it has
also had the longest theatrical release
of any movie of all time so this
terrible movie is in one respect at
least the most successful movie of all
time the success cannot possibly be
riding on the back of the good things
about the movie which is which is that
some people really love absurdity and
the Tim Curry is freakin amazing the
reason that the Rocky Horror Picture
Show is a big freaking deal has very
little to do with the movie it is about
the people that watch the movie and John
this is a really big deal to me because
what we're doing here has very little to
do with us it's a big deal because of
the people who are in it with us when
Rocky Horror started going up on
midnight screens what happened is the
wall between the audience and the movie
crumbled under the atomic blast of
user-generated content people were
bringing props and throwing them at the
screen
replacing lines with better funnier
lines and when I say better and funnier
I mean much much much more vulgar and
that phenomenon of the user-generated
movie-going experience spread in a way
that we would call viral today Rocky
Horror cult rise to fame embodies a lot
of things that we think were caused by
the Internet the desire to make content
to two-way experience the desire to
create on top of something that someone
else already create that desire was so
strong that even decades before the
internet existed people were figuring
out ways to do it in Rocky Horror is as
far as I'm concerned the best example of
that and now especially here on YouTube
that experience seems really normal and
natural so it's hard to see Rocky Horror
for what it is which is the seed of the
freaking cultural revolution so probably
what bothers me about Glee doing Rocky
Horror is that glee isn't going to be
talking about what's actually cool about
Rocky Horror they'll take out all of the
absurdity they'll take out the
cannibalistic transvestite space alien
stuff and most importantly they'll take
out the experience of Rocky Horror which
was an experience that was created by
thousands if not tens or hundreds of
thousands of individuals watching Rocky
Horror in different cities across the
world and making it their own experience
and they'll just sing some songs and the
songs are bad but they're not going to
change your life either the cool thing
about Rocky Horror is that culture that
I was once a part of and that I once
needed because because YouTube didn't
exist yet and yes I was an Iraqi caste
and points go to the common ters who
guess correctly who I played I'm looking
forward to your guesses John I will see
you on Wednesday